more and more governments around the
world are imposing lock downs and
restricting travel after the World
Health Organization declared
coronavirus a pandemic that means it is
spreading from person to person at a
very high rate in multiple countries now
if you take a quick look at this map
showing where cases have been confirmed
you see everything looks a lot cleaner
now they are currently just over a
hundred cases confirmed in Africa in 12
countries it's a small number compared
to Europe where Italy unknown has 12,000
cases the global crisis is not
widespread in Africa at least for now
they are fears that a corona virus
outbreak on the continent could
overwhelm the already fragile health
care systems in Rwanda campaigns
promoting basic hygiene like many other
African countries it's free of the virus
but still bracing for impact we have to
be afraid of this disease that way we'll
take serious measures to prevent it in
all ways before it comes if it gets here
we can keep it from spreading quickly up
until now those infected with the virus
have come from abroad so the most
stringent checks are being carried out
at ports of entry but that's not been
enough the first coronavirus case south
of the Sahara was in Nigeria an Italian
citizen who flew in from Milan
he has since infected a second person
and authorities fear such secondary
cases could pose the biggest threat
particularly if they spread undetected
DW correspondent flourish Tokoroa takes
us to the streets of Lagos where people
don't seem to be worried about the
outbreak a place where of course people
are buying and selling so there's a lot
of money exchange and physical contact
nothing seems to have changed in spite
of the two confirmed cases of corona
virus and many people here tell me that
they are not worried at all have you
heard about corona virus yes and are you
worried that it's going to be a problem
in Nigeria no no no because the way we
fight about Ebola I think with a spirit
we can rush out whenever us are not
really Norway because we were able to
welcome a bulletin obviously we'll be
able to overcome this that was a time
when this talk of Ebola so you are doing
got this see anybody not a bla effects
so I don't have any worry about this one
of the reasons why most Nigerians are
not panicking is because Nigeria is no
stranger to disease outbreaks for
example in 2014 the Ebola virus arrived
here in Lagos a city of 20 million
people it could have been an epidemic
but that virus was successfully
contained and now Nigerian health
authorities are receiving praise from
around the world including the World
Health Organization for their efforts in
stopping the spread of coronavirus
passengers coming into the country have
to undergo health screenings at
different ports of entry they must pass
on all their information to authorities
this is an example of the form that
passengers are expected to feel as soon
as they arrive in Nigeria before they
even come down from the airplane now it
includes information like bio data
information flight information health
symptoms and there's a question here
that says in the last two weeks have you
had contacted anyone who was ill or not
feeling well so after filling this form
they expected to submit it to health
officials over there on that counter the
passengers and those they have made
contact with we
contacted if there is any suspected case
of a virus on their flight even though
most Nigerians I spoke to are confident
that the virus will not affect them
experts warn that if the virus
eventually spreads there simply aren't
enough basic facilities and devices like
respiratory machines to care for all
patients so why haven't we seen as many
corona virus cases in Africa to answer
this people invited a professor or a
wily tomorrow onto the program he's a
former World Health Organization
biologist for the region of Africa
professor we'll get to that question in
a moment but first should people in
Nigeria be a little bit more concerned
about the corona virus than they are at
the moment I agree with you very much
that we should be more concerned than we
are we discover difficulties if you
track this after the tests on and this
is somebody in Nigeria who are the
fastest we still have not discovered all
of the people who track with the people
we have not been able to change so we
should be more concerned cause right now
professor Nigerians are saying things
like we beat Ebola we can beat the
corona virus is that logic correct we
see we have that chemical to control
whatever yellow fever so if you couldn't
beat those ones work is all the
confidence they work and eat their
coronavirus this is quite different from
what we are having with Ebola in terms
of the rate of transmission to the edge
which it becomes much more difficult
than for example looking at the map of
where the cases of this outbreak have
been confirmed Africa looks pretty much
clean professor if I can say the
computer you know places like Europe why
is it that we haven't seen so many cases
in Africa think that the environmental
condition the given the traveleurope
nines in winter period it is temperature
environmental temperature may be
accounting for a shot appeal of the
region being in the second solution so
we're having mouthguard
Muhsin well people these are ways to
spread the disease
so right now yes but not having it could
be two things what I said and also the
fact that we are not detected was
actually finding out professor
Africa is a very young continent does
that mean that when coronavirus does
spread that people will be better placed
to survive it I mean we've heard things
like it is the elderly and people with
existing conditions there are more
vulnerable su-22 coronavirus vary their
health situation we'll use an African
background as you expect poor
environmental conditions report as such
so I don't think we should rely too much
time the best thing is not okay it's not
that people young people are not dying
is it true that corona virus can't
survive Africa's very high temperatures
that's some of the stuff that you see
circulating on social media when you
look at the characteristics of those
viruses at human temperatures low
temperatures until be to survive on the
environment but when you get to an
environment like some of the ones you
have in action which take 30 degrees 38
degrees above 40 degree centigrade
whereas the relative survive it sticking
to them and cost compared to places in
Europe where the temperatures are mostly
okay so how well-placed
is Nigeria in terms of how would it cope
if if the number of cases were to start
increasing the pages of Nigeria can
actually be focused on two or three
places we're talking of legal a token of
Abuja I don't have the same confidence
that other states in the country as
potatoes either because these are
capitals
there are other cottages and people move
into every direction
remember uber said in begin to take
action on treating cases have been
discovered this case I want you on stage
so I'm not too sure still there are
further away from [ __ ] out
they are I don't think we take seriously
part of the country should be prepared
what Justin Lee gross effect on a budget
so if big will comes the applications
family and be going to other part of the
country I get a bit worried that the 31
days to cook
all right that's professor oh yeah well
eat tomorrow in Abuja thank you
staying on coronavirus and going down
south to South Africa which has reported
its first case of local transmission a
29 year old man in the free state
province was confirmed infected with
corona virus after contact with the
Chinese businessman now South Africa is
also bringing home more than 120 of its
citizens from Wuhan China South Africa's
President Cyril Ramaphosa has sent
military staff on the mission earlier
this week some of the returnees have
been confined to quarantine in China for
almost two months now president
Ramaphosa was at pains to point out that
none of the returnees are ill and they
will stay in quarantine once they return
to South Africa but what do people in
the country think our correspondent in
Cape Town
Adrien Krish sent us this update people
here are divided about the government's
decision to bring the South Africans in
wuhan back how many are criticizing the
timing already many weeks ago other
nations have been bringing their people
back home but the government here has
been debating and debating and they are
only taking action now at a time where
the number of cases is going down in
China and it is slowly increasing here
in South Africa on the other hand family
members are of course very happy that
this is going to happen now they've been
lobbying for it with the government for
weeks it was a very frustrating time for
many of them and although it will still
take quite some time until they can
physically see their family members
remember they have to go in quarantine
first the moment of their return is
definitely going to be a moment of
happiness and relief for them